bienvenue dans cette émission ce pas
spécial consacré à ce qui s'est passé ce
qui se passe depuis les attentats du 13
novembre
qu'est ce qui a changé qu'est ce qui va
changer dans nos vies ce sont des
questions qu'on va se poser sur
plusieurs plans sur un plan peut-être
des valeurs sur le plan aussi savoir
pourquoi autant de jeunes français sont
attirés par le par le diam sur le plan
de notre sécurité et de notre liberté
et puis aussi on va parler de la jeune
état d'urgence et peut-être de la
réforme constitutionnelle annoncée par
le président de la république pour
parler de tous ces sujets je vous
présente nos participants d'en inviter
ses fans m'ont sans professeur à la
faculté de droit de versailles saint
quentin et donc vous allez notamment
nous parler de cette réforme
constitutionnelle puisqu'il paraît que
l'article 16 peut pas c'est ce qu'a dit
président et il a raison les raisons et
vous donner un point de vue la raison
il a raison florence père kb avocate à
versailles
vous vous êtes penché ouzou beaucoup
étudié l'état d'urgence qui est ce qu'il
implique est à la fois pour les
personnes que vous recherchez mais aussi
pour tout le monde puisque c'est une
c'est un état d'urgence qui peut
s'appliquer à tous avec nous aussi
maryline bereaud pour jouer noté le
secrétaire général d'alliance police
régionale vraiment démarré mais pour la
région et nous nous barrer au évidemment
de la sécurité de 2,2 du travail des
policiers
des applications qui sont les leurs et
puis françois de sa vie mais la vie
bonjour écrivain philosophe
j'ai venir ici pour ne pas d'autre des
rives les déshérités
ces plans très bon le sur l'éducation
notamment j'ai peut-être commencé avec
vous et avec vous tous derrière mais
c'est vrai qu'on enregistre cette
émission vendredi il ya eu aujourd'hui
et l'hommage qui a été rendu aux
victimes avec beaucoup de symboles les
invalides la marseillaise le drapeau
bleu blanc rouge
est ce que à votre avis ce sont de bons
symbole est ce que ces gens là sont
morts pour la france au fond parce
qu'ils ont été traitées un peu comme des
hauts fonds comme des sols bâtis
seraient morts pour la france
ce qui est certain c'est que toutes les
communautés humaines ont besoin de rites
et elles ont besoin d'apprivoiser
d'élaborer ce qui leur arrive
notre pays traverse quelque chose comme
un vrai traumatisme est déjà en janvier
on l'avait vu dans ces moments où la
communauté nationale et frappés dans ces
moments où on ressent aussi
collectivement une forme de danger on
communie dans un risque qui pèse sur
nous en tant que nous sommes français
parce que c'est ainsi que la guerre nous
est déclarée par on pourrait évidemment
discuter de ce mot guerre mais ceux qui
nous attaquent veulent nous déclarer la
guerre au nom de ce que vous présente la
france mais ça vient qu'est ce que c'est
vraiment parce que on est français pour
ce que la france a fait rire lorsque la
france
les deux sont évidemment liées parce que
la france agit au nom de ce qu'elle
représente 2 des valeurs qu'elles
portent
en tous les cas de l'identité qui est la
sienne en tout cas ce qui est très clair
c'est que dans ce moment si particulier
on peut évidemment affirmé que ceux qui
sont morts ne sont pas morts par
accident il s'est produit quelque chose
qui nous concerne tous et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la france comme
toutes les communautés humaines a besoin
d'inventer des rites et de retrouver des
rites pour élaborer ce qui lui arrive et
c'est clairement ce le sens de cet
hommage national qui a été rendu
aujourd'hui
oui c'est très symbolique comme les
invalides bien sûr il ya quelque chose
d'un rituel dans un ensemble de symboles
qui nous renvoie aussi à notre histoire
et à ce qu'il fait là la consistance de
la communauté nationale
on voit bien que quand la nation est
attaqué on a besoin de se retrouver
autour de ce qui nous fédère de ce qui
nous rassemble de ce qui nous rapproche
à la fois de plus profond et aussi à
travers les images que
pays à partager depuis depuis des
décennies et des siècles l'impression
qu'il ya un retour aux sentiments
patriotiques
peut-être aussi un certain nationalisme
on pourrait en discuter aussi est-ce que
vous pensez que c'était un sentiment qui
va perdurer ou est-ce que c'est
l'émotion qui fait que voilà tout le
monde se regroupe derrière le drapeau
derrière le symbole de la france a bien
sûr la dimension de l'émotion nous
renvoie toujours et c'est normal à
quelque chose d'éphémère
et dans tout traumatisme il y à une
phase de deuil et après la vie reprend
son cours et la vie quotidienne reprend
ses droits en ce sens et l'émotion que
nous traversons aujourd'hui
nécessairement à la vocation à être
dépassés et non en un sens heureusement
et c'est aussi d'ailleurs la
signification de cette journée
quinze jours après les attentats que de
marquer en quelque sorte l'achèvement et
le sommet de ce travail du deuil
maintenant il faut revenir à la
construction de notre avenir commun et à
nos vies quotidiennes
cela étant dit malheureusement il est
aussi très clair que de façon assez
certaine la période des attentats que
nous avons connus marque le début d'une
phase nouvelle de notre existence
collective que la menace va durer et
avec cette menace on peut supposer on
peut espérer aussi évidemment que pour y
répondre c'est par le haut que nous
serons là la prendre et précisément par
ce sentiment national qui nous fait
tenir ensemble ces femmes sur ce soit au
plan du sentiment national
moi je fasse je suis évidemment tout à
fait tout à fait d'accord avec cette
cette belle explication je me félicite
vraiment que les français enfin aux se
réapproprier leur drapeau catherine bohl
alors l'hymne national aussi qui a été
chanté de manière très spontanée et
parfois très émouvante
ce drapeau il est enfin regardons une
seconde son histoire c'est tout sauf un
symbole de fermeture ou de frilosité à
l'égard de l'extérieur c'est aussi un
symbole de concorde
leblanc encadré par les deux couleurs de
la garde nationale leblanc royal
employés de couleurs de la garde
nationale
ce drapeau dit beaucoup de notre
histoire et de ce que nous sommes et de
ce que notre nation et
je reprends le la philosophie de renault
on a déjà parlé pour dire que vraiment
cette cette théorie de la nation c'est
un missile de chaque instant c'est le
souvenir d'une histoire commune pour
bâtir un avenir commun
là vraiment on y est alors est-ce que ça
durera c'est vrai il ya l'effet émotions
qu'ils jouent mais je pense sans doute
que la presse ne sera probablement plus
comme l'avant et il ya quelque chose
florence de notre nation de notre dos
les deux tickets d'être français qui a
été attaqué aussi par sa part ses
attentes avant oui j'en sais ce que ça
dépasse au four est ce que c'est la
liberté est ce que c'était peut-être des
choses qui dépassent la france a dépassé
la nation moi je pense qu'on a attaqué
l'humain on n'a pas craqué simplement
des français ont attaqué des êtres
humains quelle que soit leur nationalité
alors on s'est quand même voilà c'est ça
enfin tout ce que probablement la france
représentait qui est un peu mal supporté
par ces djihadistes mais ce que je
voulais dire par rapport au drapeau et à
la marseillaise qui est quand même très
étonnant c'est que drapeau et la
marseillaise qui ont traîné dans la boue
il n'y a pas si longtemps où le drapeau
français représentait pas grand chose au
mot la marseillaise été hué dans le
stade de foot où on voulait pas sortir
le drapeau bleu blanc rouge là tout le
monde se retrouve
est ce que je trouve assez fort
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est un drapeau
rassembleur et pas diviseurs et qui
rappellent nos valeurs de la révolution
française et je trouve que c'est bien
qu'on se retrouve tous autour de ça et
qu'on dépasse qu'on dépasse le
nationalisme qui est dans le sens
négatif du terme de la partie dans ce
cas politiquement en fin d'année dans
les conflits politiques
valero je pense qu'il n'y avait eu on a
vu après les attentats bhl de
scherwiller les policiers applaudi
pendant la grande tournée du dimanche
qui avait suivi les attentats de sarry
là aussi ensemble ya un rapprochement
entre autres la population et sa police
ni tout à fait tout à fait et d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs comme le disait le disait
madame ça a permis aussi de rassembler
et d'avoir de la solidarité et du
volontarisme aussi de lapin
des collègues parce que suite aux
événements qui se sont passés sur paris
le vendredi soir on a eu énormément de
volontaires de solidarité de la part de
nos collègues qui se trouvaient en repos
et qui était près même à venir pour
pouvoir donner un coup de main aux
collègues qui étaient sur paris oui tout
à fait alors d une sorte d'unanimité qui
ce fait et en même temps content quand
on regarde là puisque vous êtes
philosophe je veux parler par exemple de
michel onfray qui dit au fond c'est les
principaux responsables de ces attentats
c'est la france elle même c'est le
français
il ya quand même quelques voix
discordantes qu'on entend alors là la
discorde ou le désaccord et c'est aussi
le fondement de la démocratie attaque et
voit la perte de la parole allait être
être en scène annie mais je pense que
michel onfray
de ce point de vue là ne serait pas en
désaccord être unanimes pour défendre ce
qu'ils font de notre notre pays et ses
principes que nous partageons je pense
que aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de grande discorde de ce
point de vue là et d'ailleurs je crois
pas enfin je peux être pour pour nuancer
ce qui vient des dix je crois pas que
les français aient mépriser leurs
drapeaux ou que beaucoup de gens aient
souvent à hysacam à saliès jean luc
alphand si vous n'avez pas l'attachement
au drapeau comme on peut le voir
aujourd'hui parce qu'on dépasse
justement c'est ouais je sais pas si on
peut dire
il ya les grands événements sportifs
y avait il ya quelques événements comme
ça parce qu'il ya une forme de non parce
qu'il ya aussi une forme de pudeur nous
n'avons pas la même façon que le peuple
américain par exemple mais notre
attachement à notre histoire etc
mais je crois que le peuple français
dans sa grande majorité n'a jamais été
dans le mépris de sa propre identité
c'est peut-être malheureusement plutôt
qu'à récupérer g politique non le
drapeau le jeu c'est un peu pareil
où ça a été laissée aux six blessés ou
laissés à l'abandon et de se faire
récupérer moi je pensais qu'il y avait
17 ans quand on parlait il m'est arrivé
d'en parler aux étudiants mahfal ya
longtemps non mais non ça c'est c'est la
représentation leur envoyais vichy
jeanne d'arc
la cérémonie du 8 mai le pen etc
c'est vrai qu'il y avait quand même une
pas une méfiance mais une sorte de gêne
quoi assumer ce que nous sommes et avec
les symboles qui sont les nôtres et ça
il ya en effet une une évolution assez
spectacle avait été développé sur toute
la thématique de l'identité nationale
avec nicolas sarkozy qui essayait de
passer par ce biais là mais on n'était
pas sûr cette symbolique du drapeau bleu
blanc rouge de la marseillaise qu'on
chante tous les jours en ce moment avec
avec ferveur et effectivement quand on
prend les paroles ça correspond bien ce
qu'on vit aujourd'hui
maintenant le problème de l'identité et
il reste entier et c'est là où pour le
coup le dialogue est nécessaire pour
venir la question vous posiez les
symboles et l'attachement à ses symboles
communs mais ne trouve pas la question
de savoir qui nous sommes vraiment qui
nous voulons être quel projet n'aurait
unis et c'est là où pour le coup le le
dialogue est aujourd'hui peut-être
nécessaire que j'ai est ce que c'est une
question qui est reposé par les
attentats du 13 novembre
je pense parce que on le voit d'ailleurs
dans le
dans le communiqué terrifiant que l'état
islamique a publié pour revendiqué ces
attentats épouvantable il ya déjà une
tentative d'explication c'est à dire que
le communiqué explique pourquoi la
france est visée
elle est visée dit le communiqué en
raison de cet art de vivre qui est
désigné comme une forme de perversion ce
qui est un renversement total
et puis elle est visée aussi parce que
elle porte des racines chrétiennes une
identité chrétienne une tradition un
héritage historique et on sait très bien
que l'état islamique attaque derrière la
france ce qu'ils appellent le pays des
croisés la capitale que paris à travers
laquelle parier désigné comme étant la
capitale qui porte en europe la bannière
de la croix donc on voit bien que c'est
une identité qui est ainsi désigné cette
identité avec là pour le coup je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec vous cette
identité avec laquelle nous avons eu du
mal à nous réconcilier nous mêmes que
nous avons eu du mal à formaliser et que
peut-être nous sommes invités à repenser
non pas simplement comme un héritage
mais aussi comme un certain nombre de
principes et de projet vous ce que vous
dites je décrypte un peu c'est qu'au
fond bon la france était un pays doit je
ne tienne 1 on voit que alors il ya là
l'impératif de laïcité dont on parle
beaucoup on voit qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple des plus noël et les fêtes de
fin d'année plus pop mais fête de
printemps
est ce que est ce que quand même il n'y
a pas une gêne par rapport à ses racines
chrétiennes
oui et c'est après qu'elles soient les
nôtres et qu'elle soit toujours valable
comme comme explication comme grille de
lecture aujourd'hui c'est là pour le
coup je crois notre véritable talon
d'achille c'est à dire que à ne pas
reconnaître qui nous sommes et d'où nous
venons nous nous créons de mercredi nous
créons une espèce de vide que
précisément les pires fanatisme viennent
remplir moi je les ai vus très bien
comme enseignant comme enseignant dans
des dans des zones urbaines sensibles
dans des lieux où précisément le le raid
la radicalité islamistes exerce un
maximum de fascination elle exerce aussi
cette fascination parce que la france
donne le sentiment d'être un pays qui ne
sait plus dire qui il est et que
peut-être nos élites politiques
culturelles on tue pour pré précisément
pour principe
de déconstruire la possibilité de nous
reconnaître nous mêmes on se souvient du
débat sur les racines chrétiennes de
l'europe
je crois que le problème et je crois que
le problème est mal posé c'est à dire
que dire que la france a une histoire et
une histoire marquée par le
christianisme par exemple mais aussi par
la tradition de l'antiquité gréco-latine
et aussi par la tradition hébraïque dire
que la france à cette histoire judéo
chrétienne mais les deux de ces de ses
traditions intellectuelles
ça n'est pas à exclure ceux qui n'en
sont pas aujourd'hui les participants
c'est à dire ça ne veut pas dire que
tout le monde va devenir chrétien mais
ça veut dire que effectivement dans
l'héritage du christianisme dans
l'héritage de la raison de ricoh latine
nous puisons aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de principes très fort et prenons
la laïcité
la laïcité est évidemment en fait partie
la laïcité tire son origine de la
tradition chrétienne de la parole du
christ qui veut absolument séparer ce
qui revient au spirituel et ce qui
revient aux temporalités retrouver les
racines de cet héritage ce serait
peut-être le meilleur moyen encore une
fois de nous retrouver autour de ce qui
fait notre identité commune n'ont pas
encore une fois pour exclure ceux qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas chrétiens sont
de la majorité dans notre pays mais
simplement pour que à partir de notre
identité nous puissions nous projeter
ensemble dans l'avenir en ayant le sens
de ce qui nous rassemble c'est vraiment
et moi j'en fasse je souscris au fait
que en effet la laïcité puise ses
racines philosophique dans ce qui vient
d'être dit mais le surtout non mais en
paca de l'humanisme de la renaissance
jusqu'aux lumières la laïcité pour
s'affirmer a dû s'affirmer contre pour
une certaine par contre les dogmes
religieux et l'identité de la france
pour reprendre un ouvrage bien connue de
braudel qui n'était pas vraiment en
rapport avec cela d'ailleurs mais c'est
aussi cette laïcité qui fait sa
particularité et qui est si mal comprise
allez expliquer à les essayer
d'expliquer ce que c'est que la laïcité
alors dit à la française mais elle n'est
qu'elle n'existe nulle part ailleurs
comme il existe ici en france à un belge
et un britannique
wade et a trait à des systèmes très
proche du nôtre c'est très compliqué
d'expliquer ce que c'est et justement ce
cet espace commun la laïcité
l'offre l'offre les valeurs de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité qu'on se trouve
pas seulement au sein du champ laïque
mais qu'on retrouve particulièrement au
sein de cet espace
c'est un espace d'accueil pour tous ceux
et celles qui ne peuvent pas se
rattacher à un dogme religieux ou un
autre et puis de surcroît je pense pas
que la laïcité soit un espace vide un
espace creux il ya des valeurs des
valeurs qui sont fortes et que je suis
d'accord on peut rattacher à notre à
notre histoire judéo chrétienne on a
peut-être rappeler qui sont les nôtres
de ce point de vue là moi je fasse je
totalement jeu il faut pas il faut qu'on
peut pas renier ce que nous sommes ce
que nous sommes aujourd'hui nous le
devons aussi à ce que nous avons été et
il ya un héritage alors qu'ils qui a ses
zones d'ombré dont acte mais qui a aussi
ses lumières et qu'il faut et qu'il faut
tout à fait assumée il n'y a pas il n'y
a pas ici de malaise ou de honte à avoir
de ce point de vue là je pense que sur
ce problème de laïcité c'est qu'on a des
gens qui s'opposent entre la définition
de laïcité comme étant quelque chose de
très plein c'est à dire de tout où on
arrive à accepter tout et on vit
ensemble et puis d'autres où la laïcité
faut juste exclure tout et avoir
effectivement une zone de vide et c'est
ce que vous décrivez sur cette
problématique de zones de vie de galère
après c'est le débat est effectivement
français des gens qui veulent dire
laïcité exclusive et d'autres qui volent
des sites et inclusive et du vivre
ensemble
donc je crois qu'il ya effectivement
beaucoup d'explications texte à faire
comme le dit
justement stéphane c'est que dans les
autres pays on comprend pas très bien en
angleterre mais des communautés qui
vivent très bien les unes à côté des
autres mais en revendiquant leur leur
communautarisme
sans cette nouvelle effectivement c'est
pas notre histoire c'est pas notre
tradition et c'est pour ça que c'est
compliqué pour eux de comprendre ce
qu'on nous on essaye de le traduire en
étant cette laïcité avec tout le monde
ensemble
malheureusement d'autres vins de la
laïcité en excluant ceux qui ne sont pas
de nos origines
mais il faut pas renier nos origines ça
c'est exact marine est ce que on a vu
que la france est quand même le pays qui
donne le plus de candidats au djihad est
ce que c'est les policiers on a une
explication là dessus pourquoi pourquoi
c'est là pourquoi c'est en france qu'on
retrouve le plus de candidats au djihad
je pense peut-être qu'il ya un problème
de reconnaissance et d'identité de
certaines personnes
il ya aussi le fait d'être aussi on va
dire radicaliser ou sinon peut-être par
une par une religion et que certaines
personnes ont peut être du mal à pouvoir
à pouvoir s'identifier et d'ailleurs on
a on a un rapport entre entre la police
nationale qui représente la république
où il ya une image aussi de cette police
qui va être qui va être aussi aussi
répressive et c'est vrai que ça a été
pour rebondir sur ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure qui a été très apprécié
de la part des collègues sur le terrain
d'être d'être reconnu en tant que tel et
pas forcément montré du doigt comme
étant la police uniquement répressive
mais aussi pour protéger aussi non non
non citoyens qu'elle est utilisée quand
elle était utilisée comme ça en tout cas
les gens sont derrière elle
de plus que quand alors répression il ya
d'autres problématiques si vous voulez
au sein de la police effectivement elle
est utilisée dans ce sens là mais à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui on rencontre
énormément de problèmes en terme
d'effectif en termes de moyens on vit
aussi des événements comme on a vécu
j'ai eu des collègues qui ont été pris
mon intervenant avec des matériaux du
matériel qui est moindre on manque
énormément d'effectif on entend
énormément
moyens en terme de dotations collectif
pour vous donner une petite idée
on est en manque de gilet pare-balles
lourd on est en manque de deux casques
balistique
on va être en manque de boucliers de
taser donc donc on utilise aussi une
police on utilise aussi mes collègues
effectivement pour une sécurité qui est
nécessaire au vu des faits qui se
déroulent en réalisant inexistant
inexistant 1 le problème et le problème
étant le problème étant c'est que en
début d'année on a eu des événements de
charlie hebdo et qu' il ya eu des
demandes et il ya eu un constat aussi
d'un manquement au niveau de la police
nationale et rien n'a été fait
absolument rien exactement alors c'est
un des reproches qui a été fait au
gouvernement fait que beaucoup de gens
même parmi les familles des victimes
auxquelles il était rendu hommage
vendredi
il ya des familles qui sont pas venus en
disant mais écoutez rien n'a été fait on
a dit qu'on allait faire des choses
depuis les attentats de l'oas rien n'a
été fait ce que vous avez vert de
corroborer alors qu'en tout cas
uniquement en tout cas sur les moyens
qui nous sont accordés en tous les cas
sur les moyens dont je vous parle de
moyens et équipements au niveau de la
police absolument
on a demandé effectivement que les
collègues soient équipés raisonnablement
pour pouvoir répondre à d'éventuelles
attaques
or je vous dis quand les collègues sont
intervenus ils sont intervenus avec du
matériel moindre on est vraiment en
infériorité par rapport aux toreros aux
terroristes et donc il ya une altitude
de la part de mes collègues on demande
de la sécurité on leur demande de
sécuriser mais mais quid de leur
sécurité si on leur donne pas les moyens
il pour compléter la question de patrice
parce que la question c'est comment ça
se fait que des jeunes puissent basculer
de cette manière là vers partir en syrie
et de basculer dans le terrorisme et
devenir des jihadistes est ce que vous
ne pensez pas alors je reprends lui un
peu les propos d' emmanuel macron qui
disait qu'on a une part de
responsabilité en france sur le terreau
qu'on a laissé se développer ce que vous
pensez pas que
à une époque on avait de la police de
proximité qui était dans les banlieues
et la suppression que vous avez connus
qui ont été ce qui a été supprimé est-ce
que vous pensez que la suppression de
cette police de proximité dans les
banlieues qui était peut-être plus
proche des jeunes avec une espèce
d'abandon de c2c site et de ses
banlieues fait que ça participe aussi à
cette radicalisation
je pense pas parce que cette cette
police de proximité et de pub qu'on lui
disait à l'époque a gelé vécu je les ai
vécus au val fourré un et je puis vous
assurer que le contact avec ces jeunes
là parce que nous effectuons aussi des
patrouilles pédestres
donc c'était la possibilité aussi de de
pouvoir rencontrer de rentrer en contact
avec ces jeunes là ça restait quand même
très compliqué et très difficile le
dialogue
il y avait vraiment une image de cette
police qui étaient là qui était une
police répressive et on ne pouvait pas
dépasser un certain cap pour pouvoir
engager si vous voulez un discours et un
dialogue je veux dire constructif mais
pour les deux côtés c'était
systématiquement de l'affrontement par
rapport par rapport à ces jeunes là qui
alors pour moi et en mon sens on peut
être du mal à se reconnaître en tant qu
en tant que citoyenne de la france mais
en même temps moi un sentiment de roger
par rapport à leur pays d'origine aussi
ces échanges que j'ai pu avoir
ponctuellement avec certains qui
effectivement ce sont basculées si vous
voulez entre entre deux qu ils
recherchent une autre identité
probablement aussi vive que l'europe
jeudi dans paris ne reconnaissent pas
l'identité française 10 ans et est
d'origine
on peut comprendre entre guillemets il
lines à y rechercher une autre identité
rieur points c'est une dépossession des
103 facile
françois-xavier mais les messieurs je
rappeler le rappel le titre de votre
livre les déshérités vous rappeler les
sources au fond de d2 la crise de
l'éducation
est-ce que
justement dans cet effet que ce soit la
france qui fournissent le plus de
dialyse il n'ya pas aussi un problème
d'éducation
c'est clair et je crois qu'on revient à
ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure je
crois pas que la majorité du peuple
français se soient mises à mépriser sa
propre identité mais ce qui est vrai
c'est que nous avons construit nos
institutions et je pense évidemment à
l'école à partir de ce déni de ce que
nous sommes et du déni de l'héritage
d'une manière générale j'avais écrit ce
petit livre pour montrer à quel point
par l'école est aujourd'hui à un livre
un livre très très très humble au fond
comme un témoignage de jean ce de jeunes
enseignants qui étaient précisément
vérifié par le fait de voir qu autour de
moi toute l'école semblait construite
pour ne plus transmettre des savoirs des
connaissances une culture et que cette
déconstruction de la culture elle ne
pouvait que produire de la violence
j'avais écrit dans les déshérités que je
n'avais pas peur du choc des cultures
mais plutôt du choc des cultures et
malheureusement je crois qu'à bien des
égards c'est ce qui est en train de se
produire
le propre du dialogue parfois très
difficiles que nous pouvons avoir avec
ces jeunes c'est que précisément nous
avons le sentiment que ils n'ont même
pas à bien des égards reçu les mots pour
pouvoir entrer en dialogue et quand vous
n'avez pas les mots pour nommer les
injustices dont vous pensez être victime
les blessures que vous avez vécu pour
nommer la situation dans laquelle vous
vous trouvez et bien la seule façon de
vous exprimer cesser la violence
cette proportion française pourquoi
fournir des propos diane je pense qu'il
ya une fin responsabilités je ne sais
pas le maul je sais pas si le terme est
adapté des explications sans doute oui
l'espoir à rechercher du côté de ce que
nous sommes et de ce que nous faisons
est du côté de nos deux noms de nos
imperfections
je pensais aussi par exemple l'état dans
lequel on a laissé les prisons pendant
des décennies avant de s'apercevoir
qu'en réalité c'était des foyers de 2
des écoles de la violence etc
ça rejoint un peu ce que nous disions
mais cela dit je pense qu'il faut pas
aller trop loin non plus dans cette
recherche d'explications rationnelles
en considérant que nous sommes prêts
conte sable je crois que ça va trop loin
quand même le pays qui a fourni le plus
soir ça pose un problème à des séquences
habilité politique hors de proportion
c'est la belgique qui ont fondu de plus
ils sont ils sont beaucoup moins ils
sont six fois moi moi je leur mise en
fournissent plus proportionnés sympathie
cela dit ces réseaux c'est déjà trop
mais il ya enfin rien ne peut
rationnellement en tout cas expliqué au
delà de toutes les explications qu'on
pourra essayer de rechercher en nous
mêmes rien ne peut rationnellement
expliquer ce qui s'est passé et donc je
pense qu' il faudrait savoir où placer
le curseur de la rationalité de
l'explication et qui à un moment donné
où il ya des choses qui sont plus
réellement explicable ont cherché à les
expliquer moi je fasse ça commence un
peu à me vint à me gêner à me mettre mal
à l'aise
malheureusement les ressorts les plus
importants de notre existence ne sont
pas les plus rationnels et donc
effectivement je suis d'accord avec vous
pour dire que les actes terroristes
auxquels nous avons à faire aujourd'hui
ne sont pas rationnels
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne soit pas
explicables et il me semble à bien des
égards que nous sommes responsables
n'ont pas coupable sens où nous serions
les terroristes évidemment mais
responsable malgré tout de n'avoir pas
su donner à cette génération quelque
chose à aimer quelque chose dans quoi se
reconnaître nous avons nous-mêmes et
encore une fois il suffirait de regarder
la situation de l'école aujourd'hui nous
avons nous même tout fait en quelque
sorte pour préparer le terreau est
encore une fois je ne dis pas par là que
nous soyons coupable mais nous avons été
en quelque sorte les auteurs d'un climat
et d'un contexte qui ne pouvait que
laisser la place à ce genre de 2,2 de
délire que nous voyons aujourd'hui je
veux dire par là que et en revient à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure nous avons
beaucoup plus parler de ce qu'il fallait
détesté dans l'histoire de notre pays
que de ce qu'il convenait dès mai ou que
de ce qui pouvait être aimé nous avons
beaucoup plus parler de ce qui dans
notre culture pouvait diviser que de ce
qu'ils pouvaient réunir nous avons
entretenu nous-mêmes y compris la
question de la laïcité comme un moyen de
divisions nous avons à bien des égards
par tous ses moyens la donner a et on
sait très bien que ce dont les jeunes
ont besoin c'est de quelque chose qui
puisse les enthousiasmé de quelque chose
qui puisse leur donner l'occasion de se
donner pour quelque chose qui les
dépasse
nous avons construit un univers de
d'individualisme et de consumérisme dans
lequel plus rien ne dépasse la mesure de
l'individualité et cet univers
parfaitement horizontal il ne peut pas
combler les aspirations d'un jeune est
aujourd'hui monstrueusement et de
manière absolument atroce ce que l'état
islamique propose à ses jeunes qui la
tire c'est enfin un idéal l'occasion de
se dépasser l'occasion de se donner pour
quelque chose de plus grand qu'eux et
nous sommes ici en quelque sorte à la
fois de vendre notre échec et aussi
devant peut-être un indice de ce qu'il
nous appartient de reconstruire pour
demain mais dans les reproches que que
vous faites pour ne pas bien au fond on
pourrait dire que c'est tout l'occident
qui n'est pas typiquement français c'est
ma typiquement français mais la france
joue un rôle particulier de ce prix là
effectivement on voit la proximité avec
la belgique et la belgique
presque pourrait-on dire nous nous
précèdent dans cette dans ce chemin à
bien des égards on le voit dans
l'évolution de la société dans les
réformes de société qui ont été menées
dans la construction du lien social ou
sa déconstruction
la france n'est pas isolée et de ce camp
du ladder on voit bien que tout
l'occident est touchée par le phénomène
ministre ce phénomène djihadistes nous
ne l'avons pas d'ailleurs produit mais
nous lui avons sans doute laissé la
place tout l'occident lui a laissé la
place la place mais sans doute la france
a laissé plus de place encore et
peut-être si c'est une responsabilité
particulière maintenant pour la france
que de proposer à l'occident nous savons
bien que notre pays a une voix
singulière dans l'occident et dans le
monde c'est peut-être la responsabilité
particulière de notre pays de proposer
humblement et à sa mesure
une fondation pour reconstruire ce qui a
été déconstruit alors il ya un an
philosophie aussi un précisément la
france a influencé toute la philosophie
occidentale avec les théories de la
déconstruction qui se sont succédé sans
les années 60 voilà aujourd'hui et elles
ont eu d'ailleurs leur leur efficacité
elles ont eu
relevez cour des grands philosophes bien
sûr la fréquence uhf qui ont eu un très
grand écho par lan c'est vrai que l'on
sait aujourd'hui peut-être le temps est
venu de la reconstruction et la france
est peut-être un rôle singulier à jouer
ça pour ça nous sommes là parce qu'il ya
une difficulté particulière en effet
j'allais dire on réfléchit pas comme
ailleurs ne serait ce que parce que
notre culture si tant est qu'elles
soient transmises enseigne avant tout le
doute mais il faut savoir faire un bon
usage du doute et est allé jusqu'à doute
est sous même au point de ne plus
s'aimer
je crois que en eux c'est mens pas je
parle de la nation de la société de
l'ordre social
on ne peut pas aimer les autres et on
peut pas les accueillir et donc le doute
ne doit être que méthodique mais pas
aller au delà me semble-t-il
et on voit parfois en effet du côté des
des mois je le ressens parfois du côté
des étudiants une tentation très forte
de relativiser tous deux être tous
surtout toujours sur la même ligne tout
se vaut mais je crois que toutes les
valeurs il ya eu cette tendance quand
même une très forte hausse au
relativisme tous vos relativisme d'être
s'enracine dans cette poule dans les
années 70 a prédit beaucoup joué
l'enseignement même aux fans c'est bien
entendu alors le doute moi je fasse ça
fait partie face et ce qui fait le socle
de mon enseignement à l'université
attention parce que je pense pas ce
n'est pas que cela
mais ils font un doute méthodique c'est
à dire que tout doit permettre d'avancer
et de et de et d'adopter ce que l'on
ferait un moment donné pour un certain
temps jusqu'à ce qu'on soit persuadé du
contraire
mais cela dit vous avez raison en
soulignant qu'en france je fais les
choses ne se passent pas comme ailleurs
parce que nous avons cette culture du
doute
ancré en nous mêmes alors on va avancer
aussi sur les réponses et peut-être des
recours juridiques mais peut-être un mot
marine béraud il ya souvent un débat
entre la liberté et la sécurité
est ce que pour vous ce sont des tables
contradictoire où ses os sont des thèmes
qui vont ensemble ce que parce que s'il
ya plus de sécurité qui est apporté aux
français et puis demande ça après tout
les libertés sans risque d'être mise en
cause ou est-ce que
dit non non absolument pas je veux dire
la fin pour moi pour moi la liberté
voilà nous sommes régis par des règles
nous sommes régis par des valeurs par
des lois
à partir du moment où il ya une
application de ces lois de ces règles on
a la possibilité de pouvoir de pouvoir
être et de pouvoir exister tel tel qu'on
est
c'est tout simplement une question de
respect et d'appartenance au pays auquel
on auquel on appartient
je vais rebondir sur ce que vous disent
effectivement il ya eu il ya eu je pense
un laisser-aller et pour vous citer des
exemples
même si ça peut sembler peut-être un peu
un peu excessif il ya quand même la
restriction de la part des collègues sur
le terrain par moments pour justement ne
pas avoir de la provocation j'ai connu à
mon époque ne pas montrer des dédicaces
que ce qu'on appelle des casques au
maintien d'ordre avec une visière pour
pas aller sur sur la sur la provocation
mais je pense qu'à un certain moment sur
sur les sites et cités sensibles
il faut aussi montrer aussi que les
choses ne peuvent pas avoir des
débordements tels qu'on a pu connaître
par part par moments alors après ça la
mettre en place une sécurité
n'empêche pas la liberté tout au moins
pour pour moi on a la possibilité de
pouvoir continuer à exister et à penser
tout en respectant certaines règles
alors on va aller plus profondément dans
les détails juridiques mais peut-être un
beau sur justement liberté sécurité
selon vous
et d'abord il faut rappeler une chose
fondamentale c'est que sans sécurité il
n'ya pas dire du tout c'est à dire que
ce qui garantit la liberté de chacun
d'entre nous c'est le maintien de
l'ordre public que nous vous devons et
que nous devons à la responsabilité de
chaque citoyen dans le fait d'obéir aux
lois s'il n'y avait pas de code de la
route plus personne ne pourrait prendre
sa voiture donc il n'ya pas de liberté
sans sécurité
donc il me semble qu'il ya pas de
l'équation a attiré entre eux d'un côté
l'autorité de l'état est de l'autre côté
la liberté des citoyens cela étant dit
ce qui est très clair c'est que ya pas
non plus de liberté quand l'état devient
arbitraire et quand l'autorité de l'état
n'est plus contrôlée par les lois donc
c'est peut-être plus tôt cet équilibre
là qu'il faut aujourd'hui questionné et
le le point décisif sans doute c'est
celui on le voit bien dans cette crise
que nous traversons crise immédiate mais
aussi cette liste de plus long terme
dans cette espèce de doute qui nous
assaillent le point décisif c'est sans
doute de redonner sa vitalité sa
légitimité au travail de la production
des lois au travail législatif dans
cette situation précise que nous
traversons aujourd'hui le danger n'est
pas tant qu'il y ait trop de sécurité
autres dorment mais plutôt que la
sécurité aux lords finissent par se
faire en contournant la loi au détriment
de de la légitimité de la loi la
problématique c'est la contraction tout
c'est la tension entre la tension de
mots entre la sécurité la liberté
on va voir a dit qu'on va parler
justement cette loi du 20 novembre
2015 qui prouve l'état d'urgence pour
voir aux abords de voir un sujet
justement sur la mise en place de l'état
d'urgence samedi jour habituel de forte
affluence touristique pour le château de
versailles les grilles sont pourtant
restées fermées en raison des attentats
tragiques de vendredi soir l'état
d'urgence résultant d'une loi du 3 avril
1955 a été décrétée par le président de
la république
une mesure exceptionnelle appliquée pour
la dernière fois en 2005 qui confère aux
autorités civiles des pouvoirs de police
exceptionnel ce qui permet le contrôle
des frontières de remettre en place le
contrôle aux frontières
il renforce le pouvoir des préfets donc
le préfet peut décider la fermeture d'un
lieu public comme là on peut constater
que le château de versailles aujourd'hui
a été fermée par mesure de sécurité
donc qui permet également d'interdire le
séjour sur le département à des
individus susceptibles d'être dangereux
le préfet peut également demander aux
particuliers de restituer les armes
il peut également permettre donc aux
services de police de procéder à des
perquisitions de jour comme de nuit
ce week end en plus du château fermé
les stades et centres commerciaux
étaient déserts les théâtres vide et
toutes les manifestations culturelles et
sportives annulées
la fermeture des lieux ouverts au public
permet d'éviter le regroupement de
personnes en un lieu précis
cette mesure prise en raison de l'état
d'urgence déclaré a reçu un accueil
favorable de la part de la population et
de touristes voulaient le visiter c'est
pas une bonne chose mais je peux le
comprendre
on était venu pour la journée avec des
enfants pour voir versailles donc on a
un peu déçu mais bon on comprend très
bien je pense plutôt aux victimes et
enfin voilà que qu'elle existe et
versailles aujourd'hui donc on va
rentrer sur sur brest du coup et puis
voilà vous êtes venu spécialement à
versailles pour visiter le château
effectivement et malheureusement étant
donné les
ce qui est arrivé on peut pas visiter on
est déçu choqué le plan sentinelles a
été déployé sur paris permettant
l'intervention de l'armée française
tous les services de police de la région
ont rappelé leurs effectifs pour
sécuriser au maximum les lieux très
visitée et renforcer les équipes des
brigades parisienne une disponibilité
maximale des forces de l'ordre pour
rassurer les français
le chanteur s'est elle interrogée oui
oui
malgré ce qui s'est passé hier ont amené
ce qui s'est passé hier
oui malheureusement on n'a pas trop le
choix on est obligé de subir oui je me
sens en sécurité parce qu'on a vu quand
même intervention des forces de l'ordre
donc
personnellement ces personnes là ne me
font pas peur parce que la france c'est
quand même un état qui est fort on a des
valeurs sûres
voilà donc non non je sors dans la rue
je ne crois pas que malheureusement ça
va changer quoi que ce soit coiffer le
pire était est devant nous les on va
plus vivre simplement avec les menaces
on va vivre surtout avec la réalité des
attentats et ça va continuer et sa
vallée de plus en plus des effectifs de
police fatigué par une mobilisation
constante sur le terrain depuis janvier
dernier qui appelle à un renforcement de
leurs effectifs et de leurs moyens
techniques
laurence père cadets vous avez étudié
cette fois sur l'état d'urgence avec il
ya trois grandes mesures c'est ce sont
les l'assignation à résidence
l'impossible dissoudre un certain nombre
d'associations et les perquisitions qui
sont rendues possibles
alors comment au camp vous l'analysez
vous cette fois on a un élargissement de
ses trois grands types de mesures
puisque l'assignation à résidence alors
d'abord je vais peut-être juste donner
la définition de l'assignation à
résidence dans la loi d'état d'urgence
de 55 qui était quand même plus un peu
plus fermé que ce que l'on retrouve à
refaire aujourd'hui puisque l'article 6
de la loi de 55 disais donc que le
ministre de l'intérieur donc dans tous
les cas peu prononcé l'assignation à
résidence et cetera et cetera de toute
personne résidant dans la zone fixées
par le décret dont l'activité s'avère
dangereuse pour la sécurité et l'ordre
public
donc on parlait en 55 d'activité donc on
est sur quelque chose d'objectif parce
qu'une activité peut être qualifié de
façon claire en revanche la cet article
6 et modifiée par la loi du 20 novembre
2015 puisque maintenant le ministre de
l'intérieur peut prononcer l'assignation
à résidence de toute personne résidant
dans la zone fixe etc et à l'égard de
laquelle il existe des raisons sérieuses
de penser que son comportement constitue
une menace pour la sécurité et l'ordre
publics on est passé de l'activité au
comportement on est passé de
l'activité ont besoin à une présentation
sera des raisons évidemment je sais pas
ce que c'est que des raisons sérieuses
de penser que c'est déjà une première
analyse
qu'est ce que ça veut dire quoi
qu'est-ce que ça recouvre des raisons
sérieuses de penser que que quelqu'un a
un comportement qui pourrait donc on est
totalement
enfin je veux dire qu'on est sur la
pêche au gros et sur quelque chose
d'extrêmement l'invasion du cinryze et
c'est quand même relativement large
derrière donc sur cette assignation à
résidence
on pense que cette personne là un
comportement qui permet de penser
qu'elle va troubler l'ordre public
et du coup le ministre de l'intérieur
peu l'assigné à résidence donc elle va
être interdite de sortie pendant douze
heures de la journée 12 heures sur 24
elle doit potentiellement aussi el pais
est obligé et contraintes d'aller
pointer jusqu'à trois fois par jour au
commissariat de police donc ça veut dire
que c'est extrêmement contraignant parce
que peut imaginer quelqu'un peut être
assigné à résidence avec une
interdiction de sortir les doigts sauf
oui mais tu es quelqu'un qui a un
travail n'a plus de travail enfin je
veux dire on assiste dessine on dit
hacker la personne est assigné à
résidence de 20h à 8h du matin par
exemple et que vous allez devoir pointer
trois fois par jour au commissariat de
police de votre domicile alors qu'elle
travaille à 20 km elle va plus pouvoir
travailler donc de l'assignation sont
quand même bien voilà rien ciblé
inquiétez pas je sois assigné à
résidence il ya quand même
il vient d'être rodé et d'effets de par
le passé qui fait penser que enfin je
veux dire c'est pas on va pas assigné à
résidence une personne par hasard non
mais c'est je dis pas par hasard il a
déjà six allons quand même il ya des
signaux mais il ya des signaux aussi
contraire aujourd'hui puisque là on à
266 personnes entre le 20 novembre et
aujourd'hui on est le 27
donc en sept jours on à 266 personnes
assignées à résidence avec des recours
qui sont en cours avec des référés
administratifs puisqu'on peut contester
et il ya une préfecture qui a qui est
revenu en arrière en disant bon on est
peut-être allé un peu vite on va lever
six nations résidence donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que on s'est juste les
termes j'veux dire pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'a pas laissé les termes de la loi de
55 qui disait une personne qui a une
activité qui est là on a on est parti
sur quelque chose de beaucoup plus large
sur des raisons de penser qu'elle a un
comportement qui que quoi alors
clairement c'est que ce sont simplement
des gens qui sont sur ces à signer ce
risque elles sont gentilles et la retire
donc d'être des règles enfin des raisons
d'élargir la séquelle et le contrôle que
l'on allait avoir sur sa grille contrôle
justement alors c'est le juge
administratif juste raté parce que là
que ce soit sur les assignations à
résidence ou sur les perquisitions
maintenant qu'ils sont aussi extrêmement
large je vais vous donner aussi de la
nouvelle rédaction puisqu'elle à la loi
est également modifiée sur les
perquisitions
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on peut ordonner
des perquisitions en tout lieu y compris
un domicile de jour et de nuit alors
qu'avant on pouvait pas faire des
perquisitions sauf cas extrêmes de nuit
donc de jour ou de nuit sauf dans un
lieux affectés à l'exercice d'un mandat
parlementaire ou à l'activité
professionnelle des avocats dont il
n'aurait pas de perquisitions des
magistrats ou des journalistes patrice
vous n'aurez pas perquisition lorsqu'il
existe des raisons sérieuses de penser
que ce lieu est fréquenté par une
personne dont le comportement constituer
une menace pour la sécurité alors qu'il
est c'est à dire qu'on peut aller faire
des perquisitions dans tous les lieux
c'est peut-être des bureaux des cafés
des restaurants des tout ce que l'on
veut des lieux roues on pense que dans
ce lieu la 8e bien sûr il ya 1200 et
quelques perquisitions qui ont été
faites on a cent soixante cinq
arrestations
et ça veut dire que ces perquisitions
qui sont extrêmement large ne vise pas
que le terrorisme parce que là donc
toutes les perquisitions qui ont été
faites on a trouvé alors d'entrer des
heurts ont pas très bien mais on a
trouvé en scène on a élargi on a élargi
mais je trouve que c'est bien il faut
bien évidemment qu'il faut combattre le
terrorisme en train de dire qu'il faut
pas faire je dis simplement que là on a
peut être une atteinte à une liberté
parce qu'on peut avoir des dérives
arbitraire qui font que très bien là
dedans on va trouver des dealers et on
va en profiter pour faire une
perquisition sur alors pour que l'on
puisse mieux comprendre j'ai fait un
petit qu'à un petit exemple
petit exemple pratique que j'arrive pas
retrouvé d'ailleurs un petit exemple par
pratique sur avant et après la loi 2
j'en ai lancé je l' ai montré un sondage
quand même oui je les français les
mesures post attendant ils doivent tous
atteints mais on est d'accord 80 % sont
favorables à la déchéance de nationalité
soit sept ans en contrôle des frontières
et 66% aux assignations à résidence et
non traitement logique donc petit
exemple vous avez une personne qui est
fiché est-ce donc fichiers sc
surveillance particulière mais sur des
gens dont on n'a rien eux précisent
qu'ils n'ont pas commis de délit n'ont
pas commis de crime ils sont juste
ficher parce qu'ils ont un comportement
qui pourrait nous permettre de penser
qu'il peut y avoir une dérive donc
aujourd'hui on a dix mille cinq cents
personnes fichées ans en 2015
on avait 5000 en 2012 on en a dix mille
cinq cent en 2015
prenons un exemple une personne qui est
fiché est ce qu on la suspecte d'être
proche d'eux des shales revient de elle
revient de l'étranger on sait pas bien
où elle n'est pas recherchée à la pas
commis de délit rien et on a un
renseignement se dit que cette personne
là elle arrive en france et puis elle va
être hébergé par exemple à saint denis
chez un copain on imagine qu'on n'a pas
eu les attentats avant la loi du 15
novembre
qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire contre
cette personne rien c'est à dire qu'on
pouvait j'ai mal revient elle revient
sur le territoire français mala pas
commis de délit on peut peut-être
continuer à la surveiller non peut rien
faire depuis la loi qui a été prise à la
suite des attentats
eh ben on peut décider d'aller
perquisitionner parce que elle peut
avoir on a des raisons de penser qu'elle
a un comportement qui pourrait porter
atteinte à ses surnoms et donc bah oui
non peut-être ne trouvait rien du tout
va oui d'accord
allawi et il a on peut allé
perquisitionner ministre de l'intérieur
où le préfet peut dire très bien cette
personne là on a des raisons de penser
une ariane matériel on a rien de concret
mais on peut aller faire une
perquisition et puis allez voir ce qu'il
ya dans l'appartement de son copain à
sindou alors voilà c'est que la
difficulté moi ce qui me pose problème
dans cette
dans cette extension échappe au monde
judiciaire c'est à dire que tout va le
contrôle et le bureaucrate et c'est un
contrôle purement administratif et on
n'a pas de contrôle du juge judiciaire
c'est-à-dire que auparavant si vous en
voulez faire une perquisition
il fallait une autorisation du juge de
la détention et des libertés
donc c'était ce juge là qui donnait
l'autorisation de faire une perquisition
aujourd'hui c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur où le préfet qui donne
l'autorisation pour faire une
perquisition et ça échappe totalement au
juge judiciaire le procureur est juste
informé on lui demande pas son avis ont
la forme parce qu'on va faire une
perquisition
voilà donc le fait qu'on n'ait pas de
juge judiciaire georges ajustements
gérer cette tension entre la répression
la perquisition et la liberté il est là
le juge judiciaire pour faire ce
contrôle là il n'existe plus dans cette
loi là puisque ce n'est que le juge
administratif quelqu'un qui peut être
saisie sur sur l'abus ou sur un trend de
contrôle expliqué on se retourne borloo
et moi ça me gène unique et plus de juge
judiciaire
juste un mot la laque la question qu'est
ce que c'est quand même qu'elle ait le
contrôle le prix nécessaire aujourd'hui
alors on peut être choqué du fait que
quelqu'un qui revient de syrie soient
réveillés la nuit pour une perquisition
j'avoue que personnellement par gallant
le choc le plus
en revanche dans quelque chose de
choquant pour un citoyen français j'ai
pas dit ça il revient pas de syrie vont
y revient de n'importe parce que deux
séries avec l'ancienne où on pouvait
alors on pouvait le bélarus nouvel
arrêté on pouvait le voir on suppose que
tous les citoyens français qui ont passé
des vacances à l'étranger ne sont pas
assez speed peut-être perquisitionné
pendant la nuit
simplement parce qu'ils habitent à saint
denis il ya quand même des présomptions
réel qui s'exerce j'imagine avant de
faire une partition ne serait-ce que
patrice à sa maintenance qui peut ce qui
peut choquer et ce qui peut choquer à
bon droit les français c'est que par
exemple
reprenant l'exemple d'un résident
désormais célèbre de saint denis la
personne qui a hébergé les terroristes
dans un logement squatté à saint denis a
que des noirs avait des condamnés cet en
avant pour avoir assassiné un jeune de
17 ans avec un hachoir
qu'est ce que cette personne fait sept
ans après avant la fin de sa peine au
milieu de saint denis à être encore
susceptibles de commettre des méfaits
alors qu'il a déjà été condamné pour
après la quasi totalité des délits que
recense aujourd'hui
le code pénal violences conjugales
trafic de stupéfiants et trafic d'armes
c'est là pour le coup effectivement
alors le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
le débat autour de l'état de droit se
présente dans une mauvaise configuration
parce que je pense que la majorité des
français est littéralement exaspéré de
voir que les gens qui commettent les
crimes auxquels vous rappelleront
aujourd'hui sont tous des
multirécidivistes et que précisément par
le laxisme dont nous avons été hélas
encore probablement collectivement les
complices par notre part notre notre
refus de voir le réel en face nous
sommes aujourd'hui placé devant les
conséquences de ce de ce désordre public
qui malheureusement a progressé trop
longtemps à l'abri de l'or il essaie de
dire c'est que sur les crimes n'y a pas
de récidive tel que vous le dites je
veux dire devant parle de multirécidive
je pense que là c'est pas dire ça parce
que sans vous avez les taux tout les
tous les terroristes qui ont été engagés
et impliqués dans l'est dans les
derniers attentats en france pas
seulement ceux du mois de novembre mais
les fraises kwasi amedick deux libanais
et tous ceux qui les précèdent mohamed
merah étaient tous multirécidiviste il
avait l'érotisme et de verizon général
sur ils avaient tous été libérés avant
la fin de leur peine respectives il ya
il ya quand même un vrai problème qui se
pose aujourd'hui en france ça arrive de
moyens enfin je veux dire non non c'est
un problème aussi de volonté politique
et ses problèmes d'affirmation de la
justice dans notre pays bien sûr que si
parce que les juges que ce soit les
juges d'application des peines où que ce
soit les juges de façon générale et
c'est pas pour rien que là on est en
train de recruter des juges parce que
ils n'arrivent pas à suivre donc sa
volonté politique et les moyens
évidemment ça mais ça prenne ça peut
faire un problème de moyens mais quand
je dis la récidive de façon générale en
dehors de preuves de terroristes à
récidives en matière criminnelle très
faible très faible
oui il fallait parler des gens et non il
parle et or qui avaient été appliquées
dans les actes terroristes événements
sont un mot peut-être sur le le juge
administratif on peut lui faire moins
confiance que j'ai fait parce que
florence a dit elle le soupçonne pas de
distinguer ainsi fait moi je suis un
observateur donc je joue
deux drops je défends je défends ni l'un
ni l'autre si vous l'aimez mais florence
l'a très bien dit ça pour qu'on peut
résumer les choses en disant j'avais un
professeur qui qui qui parlait un peu
comme cela
florence a dit on va à la pêche au gros
et une professeure bien-aimée 10 elle a
le droit applicable dans les situations
d'exception c'est vous vous mettez une
cantate de bach d'un côté une musique
militaire de l'autre et vous avez voilà
le paysage qu'il fait quand il est grand
et c'est des gros ça veut et c'est là on
y va à la serpe est très large
le problème c'est que il ya des
questions de droits et libertés qui sont
en cause ce qui me gêne moi c'est pas
tant l'absence du juge judiciaire même
si notre tradition je me dis que c'est
en effet du jeu disait gardien de la
réserve naturelle de la liberté fin
naturelle pas un terme que je chéris
m'enfin ce qui me gêne c'est plutôt le
fait que le contrôle interviennent à
posteriori le gicam à sa demande avant
le juge ne sera dit c'est un vrai juge
qui est au moins aussi un des blessés
d'après mais ça vient après la
difficulté peut venir de là il ya un
recours il ya une série de recours
possibles fleurance l'a bien signalé
devant le juge admiratif mais cet après
alors un mot rapide non parce que
malheureusement le temps passe très vite
il va y avoir une réforme
constitutionnelle enfin le congrès va
être convoqué le président de la
république a dit l'article 16 fameux
article 16 n'est pas un pli câble
l'article 36 sur l'état de siège non
plus en quoi en de boer a consisté ne
peut consister cette réforme
constitutionnelle est est ce qu'elle est
utile c'est un vaste sujet oui je crois
qu'il ya derrière cela avant tout un
message politique voire symbolique parce
que l'expérience montre jusqu'à présent
que le dispositif de 55 à mende est
comme ça a été le cas par la loi du 20
novembre s'avère relativement suffisant
le l'avantagent d'une révision
constitutionnelle serait peut-être de
rendre les diverses mesures susceptibles
d'être prises un peu plus robuste en les
mettant notamment lors c'est l'argument
qui est développée mais c'est un
argument un peu gênant en les mettant
notamment à l'abri d'une possible
censure de la part de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme puisque dans la
hiérarchie des normes et des
juridictions la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme est là
et la cour européenne sont au dessus du
jeu original mais au-dessous du juge
constitutionnel
donc ce serait si vous voulez cette
affaire de faire grimper d'un étage le
dispositif applicable
sauf que alors le la révision est par
exemple serait indispensable si on
souhaitait on n'a pas parlé mais si on
souhaitait inscrire dans un texte la
possibilité de déchoir de sa nationalité
oui s'il faut pas faire alors qu'ils
auraient qui serait d'origine française
on peut pas faire aujourd'hui tout
simplement parce que la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
l'interdît donc sauf à dénoncer la csdm
ce qui me paraît totalement surréaliste
la seule solution serait de faire
grimper cette norme
au dessus c'est à dire dans la sphère
constitutionnel voilà alors cela dit je
ne vois pas spécialement de s'ils
voulaient d'urgence a opéré sa vision ne
serait ce que précisément parce que nous
sommes en situation d'urgence et qu'il
est toujours malsain de vouloir toucher
au texte fondamental la constitution a
été révisée 24 fois depuis 50 ans ne
s'est pas la question mais pas dans de
telles circonstances il faut prendre le
train et on en parlait tout à l'heure je
rejoins ce que ce que vous disiez à
savoir qu'on a l'impression que pour
régler une question régler un problème
dans l'urgence on prend un texte sur le
coup de l'émotion l'a bien sur le plan
pénal vais en refaire on n'a pas arrêté
de faire si bien qu'on a aujourd'hui des
textes donc on ne sait que faire qui
s'empilent qui sont pas appliquées parce
que pas applicable qui se contredisent
les uns les autres qui ne sont pas
compris on en a déjà parlé y compris
parfois je ne devrais pas le dire mais
pas par les enseignants avec magistrats
les enseignants ou on essaie de
s'accrocher et c'est très compliqué
d'expliquer des choses inexplicables un
étudiant mais met donc la révision de la
constitution doit se faire d'une main
tremblante 10 10 la trâlée les airs et
voilà donc il faut être prudent avec
cela et je pense pas que ce soit
vraiment le moment de passer à une
révision constitutionnelle
un mot alors de conclusion puisque dans
la savane de minutes je voudrais qu'on
voir un sondage les français
plébiscitent le gouverneur gouvernement
d'union nationale est-ce que
ça pourrait être une solution françois
lamy d'abord ce plébiscite il se formule
à partir d'une intention la question de
savoir comment il se dessinerait serait
nécessairement gouvernement très large
c'est-à-dire qui comprendrait aussi le
front national d'après d'après les bases
du sondage en tout cas la
matérialisation de ce gouvernement
serait nécessairement sujette à des
désaccords qui ferait peut-être baisser
le taux de ce sondage
maintenant ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
la solution elle est politique mais pas
seulement politique elle elle est même
bien en amont de la politique elle
concerne la la question de savoir de
façon beaucoup plus durable au delà des
gouvernements qui nécessairement
passeront et se succéderont comment
comment nous voulons dessiner cet
équilibre dans nos dans nos principes
républicains les plus fondamentaux pour
répondre à la crise terroristes que nous
traversons aujourd'hui
et de ce point de vue là un gouvernement
d'union nationale serait sans doute un
peu fragilisé par la difficulté à donner
un cap qui soit claire et à se donner
des lignes politiques fortes je crois
que ça n'est pas parce que nous sommes
tous pour l'union nationale qu'il faut
que ça implique une suspension grand
désert politique et des démagogues
erratique au sol sur le louvre au total
ce commentaire que chaque parti
politique est un programme et des idées
une vision et un projet on arrive une
beyrouth
ce que vous demandez vous c'est quoi
plus de moyens parce que on sait que
tous les spécialistes que les u7 à
tozeur des 13 novembre que ça sera
probablement malheureusement pas le
dernier et qui risque d'avoir d'autres
attaques
vous demandez quoi plus de moyens alors
du conseil alors plus plus de moyens
avant toute chose plus d'effectifs on a
eu quand même une annonce du président
de la république pour la création un
poste à hauteur de 5000 pour les
gendarmes et les policiers
maintenant il faut savoir que en termes
de recrutement on a quand même une
disponibilité de deux ans et demi pour
que l'aide soit fermée il ya un an
donc on a d'autres solutions si à mettre
à mettre en pratique pour pouvoir avoir
effectivement des effectifs qui vont
être opérationnel mais plus de moyens
plus d'effectifs pour pouvoir assurer au
mieux la sécurité de la france
merci beaucoup à tous les cas merci
beaucoup en france
merci à marie l'hérault merci florence
mercadier merci stéphane minson